freundin a wie geht's euch mir geht's
super danke der nachfrage ich glaube
kann hat mich gefragt allerdings meine
damen und herren wir haben uns hier
heute versammelt weil ich ein video
entdeckt habe auf der plattform youtube
was heißt konkret wollte mein leben
zerstören das ist ein video von dem user
achse der meint in der beschreibung des
videos ich konnte es selbst kaum glauben
er wird doch immer so nett pumpen und
aber kompakter luca hat es tatsächlich
getan
habe ich getan vielleicht bekommen wir
in den text darüber aufschluss was ich
eventuell getan haben könnte hier steht
com crafter wahrheit kong crafter
konkret pranken crafter enthüllt
also anscheinend erfahre ich in diesem
video die wahrheit über mich das video
geht nur eine minute 35 deswegen würde
ich sagen schauen wir vorher ganz kurz
in die kommentare hier steht nämlich
beispielsweise das ist so trocken und
scheiße dass es wieder lustig ist
trocken und scheiße finde ich gut der
talent lose luca unterhält er niemanden
hey du bist jetzt blockiert man ich
lachte ich aus warum wird er von seiner
community ausgelacht wenn steht ihr noch
sowas wie wow das in komplett zerstört
ich sehe profi vielleicht schon
konkreter von axel verprügelt eine
verständliche reaktion blabla ich dachte
nicht auf blabla also hier sind echt
einige kommentare die einerseits gegen
ihn und gegen mich gehen da wir uns
jetzt allerdings die tags die
beschreibung des videos und die
kommentare angeschaut habe würde ich
sagen schauen uns jetzt mal wirklich das
video an
ich verstehe kein einziges wort was
macht er der lacht mich jetzt weiß ich
sogar noch ich hab da ein video
hochgeladen einen blog wo eine freundin
von mir einen hund hatte und ich musste
kurze zeit auf den augen passen und er
hat geschrieben hätte auch gerne hund
und ich hab gelacht als antwort tut mir
leid an der stelle
[Musik]
luca ja das bin definitiv ich meinem ist
gerade dieses szenario vorstellen da ist
ein typ mit seiner kamera auf einem
maisfeld einer matratze oder einem
kissen wo ich drauf geklebt bin und er
könnte so germany's next topmodel
gewinnen aber ich mein eventuell hatte
er auf dem grund und deswegen schauen
wir das jetzt mal weiter an luca das
feld hier ein mit auszulassen
ich denke mit leuten machen
[Musik]
da hat der hilfen luca bestimmt schon
ganz okay ich passe auf also part 1 die
erniedrigung okay
ras
hat er mit mir grad wrestling neben
einem maisfeld gespielt in der tat hat
zwei die zerstörung er nimmt mich und
macht genau das gleiche wie sat 1 also
wir können mal kurz mal zurückgehen das
hier ist part 1 die erniedrigung
dann nimmt er mich und zeigt auf mich
nimmt mich nun und schmeißt mich so auf
den boden suchen jetzt kommt hat zwei
die zerstörung dann nimmt er mich so und
schmeiß dich genauso auf den boden
hahaha okay da kam noch einen schritt
hinterher bei k2 und das war dann der
unterschied zum teil eins also das hat
mich getroffen schmeißt nicht noch mal
auf den boden und jetzt nein
schmeiß ich komplett drauf aber jetzt
kopf abreißen keine ahnung was das jetzt
soll also erst meist sie wieder auf den
boden und irgendwas mal seine maske
wahrscheinlich weg ist verwandelt sich
das für mich warum ausmachen
deswegen ich bedanke mich und gucken ja
dieses video mit abonniert mich okay du
kriegst von mir auf jeden fall jetzt
erst mal direkt und halten
[Musik]
wenn ich da passant wäre und daher
laufen würde ich würde direkt polizei
rufen was war denn jetzt eine mission
mit diesem video also ich habe unter
einem video von mir einen kommentar von
ihm kommentiert und er hat in meinem
kopf ausgedruckt
und auf einen kirchentag dann hat das
kissen geboxt also
scheiße
ich schreibe erst mal wo du hast mich
komplett zerstört jetzt bin ich aber
traurig
das war's jetzt allerdings von video
meine damen und herren ich habe nur
dieses video bei mir am rand gesehen und
dachte mir so hessen leben habe ich
jetzt zerstört wenn euch meine rechner
aufgefallen da würde ich mich gern mal
über einen like von euch freuen dann
müssen wir das heutige video selbst ein
kurz geworden ist allerdings habe ich
heute auch einen blog aufgenommen und
der kommt morgen und der wird dann
wieder ein bisschen länger und da habt
ihr mal wieder ein blog und hey was ist
13 durch null schreibt sie die
kommentare riches